because it means
everything to you.
>> GOA GOA FACING INCREASED
BACKLASH OVER BORDER POLICIES
INCLUDING LIMITS ON I.C.E. WHEN
IT COMES TO ARRESTING ILLEGAL
RESIDENTS.
>> THREE REPUBLICAN SENATORS
ARE PUSHING BACK WITH A NEW BILL
AIMING TO ALLOW POLICE TO
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAW.
JEDEDIAH:  ALABAMA SENATOR TOMMY
TUBERVILLE IS HERE TO EXPLAIN.
TELLS US WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> NOT A LOT OF COMMON SENSE,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
ESPECIALLY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THIS EMPOWERING LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACT THAT I PUT FORTH, BASICALLY
THEY CUT THE LETS OUT OF I.C.E.
-- LEGS OUT OF I.C.E.
APPREHENSIONS ARE DOWN ALMOST
70%, WITH THE INFLUX OF MIGRANTS
COMING IN, THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
WE WANT TO POWER LOCAL AND STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHICH NOW THEY DON’T HAVE
JURISDICTION, BUT GIVE THEM
AUTHORITY TO WORK WITH I.C.E.,
TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO, TO
APPREHEND AND EXTEND THE 180 DAY
PERIOD.
RIGHT NOW IF WE CATCH SOMEBODY
FOR MURDER, RAPE, CHILD
MOLESTATION, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, WE CAN’T HOLD THEM AFTER
180 DAYS.
AFTER 180 DAYS WE HAVE TO TURN
THEM OUT, FREE PEOPLE, WHICH
WILL BE IN THE UNITED STATES,
NOT OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY.
>> IT MAKES OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY’S JOBS ALL
THE MORE DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS
WESTDANGEROUS.
WE WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT AN
OP-ED, IT’S JAR, IT SAYS I’LL
KEEP PENSIONS SAFE FROM
COMMUNISM.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT.
>> THIS TIME LAST YEAR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND LARRY CUD
LOW SENT A LETTER SAYING WE
WON’T EMPOWER CHINA WITH
INVESTING $700 BILLION OF THE
MILITARY’S PENSION PLAN AND
CITIZENS THAT WORK FOR THE
GOVERNMENT.
$700 MILLION THEY WERE GOING TO
INVEST IN CHINA BUSINESSES.
CHINA BUSINESSES, THEY DON’T
PLAY BY THE RULES.
THEY COMMIT CORPORATE ESPIONAGE.
THEY VIOLATE U.S. SANCTIONS AND
THEY DON’T COMPLY WITH BASIC
AUDIT AND REGULATORY STANDARDS.
WE DO NOT WANT TO EMPOWER THE
MILITARY OF CHINA.
THEY’RE OUR ADVERSARY, OUR
ENEMY.
THEY’RE GROWING EVERY DAY.
IT’S RIDICULOUS WE WOULD PUT ANY
PENSION FUND MONEY INTO CHINA.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE OF ZERO
TOLERANCE TOWARDS CHINESE
AGGRESSION AND IF WE DON’T DO
THAT, THEN WE’RE GOING TO BE WAY
BEHIND THE GAME WHEN IT COMES TO
KEEPING UP WITH OUR THEIR ECONOM
AND THEIR MILITARY.
>> TWO BILLS COMING FORWARD
THIS WEEK.
SEE YOU HOW THOSE PROGRESS.
WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK.